I wonder if you think it's a
school It's the first time since the opening of this prestigious private school, Suzaku High School I'm
late and I'm leaving early Repeatedly every day
Fighting all over the place If I fall asleep in class
I'm 6  I've always brought a class diary for girls.
I'm sorry, but I
don't know anyone.
I thought it would be more interesting, so I'm an
honor student to
[music]
I'm here Goooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo
you're dead?
I
mean, what are you thinking of going back to the Little Kyoto
classroom?  Were you serious,
sir, in
this case, is it possible to replace the sea of ​​a and c
?  I don't know you got a blow job
You can be so calm
No matter
how you think about it, the cause is that we both fell
down the stairs
So it's not just a matter of doing the same thing again
I'm going to the stairs right
away.  I'm not sure if I've recovered
[MUSIC]
Wait until after school
What the hell
is this happening because you missed the stairs so I'll have you drink on this condition
That's right, but I
say so, c  Hey,
wait, isn't
this
a chance?  Okay,
this is still
nan
yeah
What's wrong with the company?
I gave it to you, so let's eat together Let's
adjust it appropriately
Oh yeah, let's eat It's
an unusual
lunch box for him, but it's okay to eat
it  It
might be better to
leave it on the 4th.
I'm sorry
, I didn't mean to make you feel bad again
.
Okay, you don't want to skip class I guess I'll wait.
Okay,
don't get in the way. What were you talking about with Yamada at the ranch on the 4th? It's not a big deal
.  I think you know what will happen if you give me care
[Music] It was
far away
What kind
of situation is Honda
?
It makes the web fun,
what are you doing
You idiot, what are you doing?
It really was 1100-1 days.
That's my line
But don't go back to your house
and shine the light in front of you I
don't understand
But
when Sasaki-san ran away with his tail wrapped around me
Thank you very much Pokon
[Music]
This guy is surprisingly honest.
Anyway, only 5th place
.
I don't want to drink.
When we fell down
the stairs, it hurt
.
Even if I do this, it's a waste of time
.  Maybe
[music]
Let's go
Yeah,
we're gonna say it again, let's keep Hohoko a secret between the two of us
Ah,
what happened to kiss me out of habit?  I can do it
because I like Mr. Yamada
Seriously,
it would be terrible if it was found out that I was followed by you after being replaced.
Oh, it's a
little scary, but it's cool
[Music]
Can you lend me a little bit?
Second, it's not like you're on
good terms c Well, you're an
honor student  There's no point of contact with the
delinquent Yamada.
I really don't have anything, so no, don't hesitate to put it out I'll leave it to you, but it seems like a heavy tax
[music]
Shitsuiku-chan
ah ah ah
par
I'm sorry Rory said it's okay but it's okay but I definitely want to remember it
I'm not going to promise a date with Mr. Shirai Eh, I'm
convinced by this,
you're Yamada
Yeah,
it's before.
Well, there's no need to hide it now.Anyway, why don't you go out with me?When
I took the make-up exam,
Mr. Yamada wasn't in the classroom, and Mr.
Miyamura found out the secret.
Listen,
no, I'm
going to offer you this room, but
I'm sure you've decided on your influence,
right? Right now, you need a place
to switch places at school.  Hey you, the
bills are too good.Listen to me.This place
was used by the Paranormal Phenomena Research Club as a companion.I'm the
only member of the club, and it's about to be distributed.If
you guys become members, you can use it
freely.Freely.  You're welcome to use it, but there's one problem I'd like to clear up. Have
Yamada and Shiraishi-san ever kissed anyone else?
It's the first time for both
of us If it's the first time for both of us, then there's a
possibility, isn't it?  It's okay, it's okay, you're
kissing between cool guys Excuse Mei-chan
I'm also interested, so please consider it
Eh, what's up with the softness?
put in
It's changed, this is Yamada's dagger,
bang,
it's been a long time
, right?  Oh, wow,
no 4.
Amazing. Maybe if you kiss, everyone
will switch places.
I don't know
.
Why
do you oppose me?
2. You can't forgive me for kissing another woman
.
5Door Shirai-san, it's fine if you
join the Nagakane club.
I don't think it's a
bad story.Is it
okay?Shirai j I don't have anything to do with [music]. Club activities
seem to be kind of fun.
[Music]I
understand.
It's starting,
Mr. Shirai is the vice president, I
'm Yamada.
[Music]
What did you do with the kiss with Oiyama Shirai-san
?